[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
a california appeals court orders a
review of the infamous murder conviction
of scott peterson
what's it mean for the case exclusive
interviews are coming up
plus a judge orders the release of new
video in the cases against the officers
accused of killing george floyd also a
major meth bust on the west coast
the shocking volume of drugs seized and
you'll hear from an admitted murderer
who wants to change his guilty plea
as he blames an attorney he once tried
to fire
for botching his case long crime daily
covers court cases from coast to coast
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm erin keller along with terry
austin brian buckmeyer is off tonight
the california supreme court has ordered
the murder conviction of scott peterson
to be
re-examined peterson was convicted of
murdering his wife lacey and their
unborn child
conor on christmas eve 2002 but the
state's highest court is now telling a
san mateo county
judge to determine if peterson should
get a new trial
the court is agreeing with an appeal
filed by peterson's defense
on one matter writing juror number seven
committed prejudicial misconduct by not
disclosing
her prior involvement with other legal
proceedings
including but not limited to being the
victim of a crime
peterson was sentenced to death but the
state supreme court overturned that
punishment in a separate appeal this
past summer
peterson's defense says he did not get a
fair trial
but we have publicity in this case that
covers inadmissible evidence evidence
that didn't exist
evidence that was ruled and admissible
uh things like
the attorney general's of the state's
statement that the
conviction was certain they had a locked
solid winner
statements like articles about defense
counsel
believing his client was guilty uh
articles about evidence that had been
specifically ruled inadmissible
articles covering evidence that didn't
even exist
we have a situation here we had those
billboards placed outside on the freeway
with a picture of scott peterson asking
expected jurors to go
man or monster with a telephone number
state prosecutors meanwhile insist scott
peterson's conviction
should be upheld in part because they
argued the trial was fair
that there was an ebbing flow to the
coverage
in this case and most of the coverage
understandably occurred when lacy went
missing
and so by the time we got to trial
there had been basically an ebb
in in the publicity and so therefore my
suggestion
is that those surveys were highly
probative
when the evidence when the publicity was
at its highest
and as the trial judge i think said here
the only place that this case could have
gone
where no one would have heard about it
was mars
and that was true everyone had heard
about this case
many questions here attorney mark
garagos represented peterson at trial he
joins us now
live on this broadcast attorney garagos
thanks for joining us
thank you good afternoon good to see you
here peterson filed this petition for
habeas corpus in 2015 and the state
court disagreed with 18 of the 19
claims so this is primarily just a
dispute about the juror who failed to
disclose
that she once feared for the life of her
own unborn child
because her boyfriend's ex-girlfriend
was harassing her
what was your fear during trial was your
fear that that juror might sympathize
too closely with victim lacie peterson
or was it just a fear that that juror
lied during voir dire
well look this is what happened the
supreme court first as you
talked about the setup piece just
reverse the death
the death penalty so they have the
option now of retrying the penalty phase
but before they got to that or made a
decision
they now have uh issued what's called an
osc order to show cause to the
trial court as to why the conviction
should not be set aside and
you aptly put they specifically honed in
on this one issue and this issue is a
significant issue
we complained in real time 20 years ago
that we kept
exposing or finding what i called at the
time
stealth jurors meaning jurors who were
lying
and had an agenda to get on here and
frankly every single one that we
identified
was lying to get on here to convict him
we caught
a couple of them in real time this juror
we did not but
i was not as concerned about her at
at least when she was an alternate when
she
after the judge uh pulled off and
eliminated
a couple of jurors who had indicated
that they
that they were hung she was placed into
the jury and she
is obviously a troubled young woman and
and the
subsequent investigation showed that
when she filled out the forms
she had absolutely lied about the fact
that she had had a restraining order
and that she had had an encounter with
another woman
and that was exactly what another juror
who we had found and exposed during
bought here
had done and then later to that that
other juror had admitted that she was
lying
to get on there to fry scott her words
fry scott
so this is a significant issue obviously
i've maintained
for close to 17 years that scott is
innocent and that this was a
um this was a mob verdict and hopefully
now he'll get the justice he deserves
so the core of the case here though
appears to be intact you know all of
these other points that were raised
during this specific appeal
issues about whether or not the state
improperly presented evidence about the
growth of the unborn child
about the dog scent about exactly where
the bodies were alleged to have been
placed in the water
about your own defense strategy and
these questions about whether
lacey was seen by other people walking
the dog after scott went
to go fishing those questions the
appeals court turned around and said
we apparently don't have a big issue
with those so is the core
states case strong enough here because
it appears that remains intact
well it doesn't really matter at this
point if they find
that she had committed the error that
she
that they've already found which is an
osc means there's
basically probable cause prima facie
they've made it you've made a case out
that there was prejudicial um uh
uh effect or conduct if that's the case
none of that other stuff matters because
you have to set aside the conviction so
we can argue about the other stuff and
frankly that will probably end up in the
uh
federal court if this doesn't uh
uh gain traction but it's already gained
traction i think that frankly
what's happening here is that the
supreme the cow supreme
knew knows exactly what they're doing
they had said
remember the exact reason that they said
they reversed the death penalty is
because the prosecution
had sat back and let the judge over our
objections at trial
seat jurors who were pro-prosecution who
were pro-death penalty
and had eliminated all jurors who said
that they had
issues with the death penalty uh my
argument has always been
if that's the case and that's the law
and clearly it is the law from the u.s
supreme court the california supreme
court
how does a juror who is pro-prosecution
for the penalty phase not pro
prosecution or the guilt phase well
now we're going to find out because if
this juror
did commit what it appears she did do
then the verdict itself is tainted and
must be thrown out
biased jurors are a huge concern i have
seen judges in other cases we have
covered here turn around and claw a
verdict back and say we've got to start
from scratch because of an issue
with a juror it happened in the shayna
hubers case in northern kentucky near
cincinnati for instance
and that was another high profile case
where this was an issue slightly
different issue
but it's happened so okay what does it
mean if your former client gets
a new trial how does that play out what
it means to
what it means and if you play it out
there's no way they convict him
i i just don't believe that's gonna
happen i mean people can talk about
he's guilty he's guilty he's guilty the
fact is nobody knew
knows or knew that evidence better than
our team did in real time
and there wasn't a single person on the
team who didn't feel as if
there was a complete collapse of any
evidence by the way
including the trial judge at various
times during this case
um and so there i there there
is no there is no to my mind
justice that has been for lacey for
scott for conor or for
either of the families attorney mark
garagos appreciate you joining us here
on law and crime daily for the insight
you were there for it you know it
perhaps better than anybody else
thank you very much i appreciate it i
want to switch now very quickly to terry
austin and eklund mercy a criminal
defense attorney in atlanta georgia
who's also joining us
uh terry real quick here your thoughts
on this does this case deserve to go to
get a new trial based on
what we know about this juror well you
know the interesting thing about this
juror
is she might have been asked were you
involved in other
court proceedings or a lawsuit and she
may not have understood
that the restraining order is a court
proceeding
actually it really doesn't matter what
her understanding was
if in fact she did not answer that
question correctly
it could very well be a legitimate
reason
for sending this back to the tribe and
attorney eklund mercy your thoughts very
quickly
um i i think once a case has at least
two
made for tv movies that an appeal was
going to be
granted at some time like you knew this
was going to happen it was like one of
the biggest cases
everybody wanted to be on that jury it
doesn't surprise me that this came
up we're going to talk to both of you in
just a moment as law on crime daily
continues a series of arguments today in
a minneapolis courtroom in cases
involving the alleged murderers of
george floyd
prosecutors are accusing a defense
attorney for one of the officers
of filing documents and making them
public before they can be ruled
admissible
one of the reasons for the request is
because the defense
wants to admit video of an earlier
arrest of george floyd in 2019.
the judge ruled that material could be
made public
but has not ruled on whether it can
actually be used at trial
and still ahead here on law and crime
daily authorities in a neighboring state
make a decision on whether to charge
a teen accused of gunning down three
people at a protest in kenosha wisconsin
also a decision from a pennsylvania
prosecutor over whether the police
shooting
of a knife-wielding suspect was
justified our experts weigh in when law
on crime daily returns right after this
and welcome back everybody the teen who
shot three demonstrators and killed two
of them in kenosha wisconsin
will not face gun charges in his home
state kyle rittenhouse
is accused of bringing an ar-15 style
weapon to the disturbances
and pulling the trigger in what his
attorney called self-defense
the prosecutor's office in lake county
illinois where rittenhouse lives
says there's no evidence the rifle was
ever in illinois
they say the rifle was bought and stored
in wisconsin where rittenhouse remains
charged with first-degree intentional
homicide
a pennsylvania district attorney has
announced the police officer will not
face charges for shooting a
knife-wielding man
according to the lancaster county d.a a
woman called 9-1-1
saying ricardo munoz was trying to break
into her home
the woman asked for munoz to be brought
to a hospital for mental health care
an unnamed officer responded to the home
when munoz suddenly appeared at the door
and ran at the officer holding a knife
that's when the officer shot and killed
munoz
an investigation determined munoz was
four to seven feet away when the officer
pulled the trigger
the prosecutor is calling the officers
accidents justified
former nypd detective and law and crime
expert kirk burkhalter says
better training can help departments
avoid situations like these
so this is a it's a tragedy and we've
seen this movie before we've seen
emotionally disturbed persons
confront police and then there's no
choice right it escalates or there's
it immediately escalates and someone has
to
be the victim of deadly physical force
through
no fault of either side um and
the focus is always on the incident
right those the seconds right there when
those shots are fired
and i believe the focus should be on one
the training and education of the police
officers
and quite often uh departments don't
necessarily have the resources to train
police officers to deal with this
particular situation
however there are other resources and
jurisdictions there are medical
professionals
there are hostage negotiators within the
police department
so when that call is made to the police
department
that hey there's someone in my home
they're acting aggressively i fear for
my life they're dangerous
that goes beyond simply send the police
we're doing the police a disservice
we're doing society a disservice
let's jump in now with some analysis
eklund mercy let me start with you
in your view is this one justified did
the d.a get the review
right or not right well i i don't know i
think that
it was it's all fact-based
so it should have been a jury question i
feel like when
when we're dealing with facts of who
felt for
you know you felt for the fear for your
life
i need the facts so that's something a
jury decides for the
prosecution to take that out of their
hands i don't think that that was their
place
i understand that there are some
defenses but
unless you do that for every single um
immunity case then you shouldn't do that
just because he's a police officer
i feel that people should just you know
the justice should be
spread evenly so unless the prosecutor
does that for
every single self-defense case in which
they look at it
and say hey these facts say you know
what we shouldn't prosecute
then that's fine but if that's not the
case then it should have went to jury
interesting perspective there eckland
now terry a lot of people might turn
around and say hey look if the officer
is
threatened then the officer has a right
to defend himself
eklund's looking at it purely from a
legal perspective that you know
we should force a trial here do you
disagree or not
well you know under the law deadly force
is justified if in fact
it's necessary and there's no other
lesser way to handle the situation
i think the answer here is to make sure
not just the police officers are coming
but that people who can handle the
situation from a psychiatric standpoint
also answer those types of calls
interesting perspectives here out of
eclin and terry we'll see you again
later on in the broadcast and later on
drugs drugs and
more drugs one of the largest fines at a
stash house ever made
in the united states plus a brazen theft
caught on camera
of an object you usually don't see
stolen
we talked to the restaurant owner who's
happy police caught the culprit on your
[Music]
screen
[Music]
federal authorities in los angeles
announced the largest domestic seizure
of methamphetamine
in recent times the dea says more than
2200 pounds of meth
that you're looking at right here were
taken from a stash house
according to the agency's director
that's more than enough to provide
a dose of meth for every man woman and
child
in the united states and mexico
agents further found nearly 900 pounds
of cocaine and 13 pounds of heroin
packed inside duffel bags ready to be
distributed the seizure was part of
operation
crystal shield targeting cartel
operations
weird case caught on camera in downtown
cincinnati ohio
surveillance video from a sports bar
shows a suspect
backing up his van and stealing a
barbecue smoker of all things
the man took off with the smoker in tow
and one day later police say they
tracked it down
officers returned the smoker to the
restaurant yesterday and this man mark
thomas
faces a felony theft charge the rightful
owner of that smoker is grateful to have
the item back at his business
i'm excited you know i cook on it all
the time and some days i'm like oh i got
to do more wings today
but i couldn't be happier today i'm
going to be doing wings all day
and some pork and some turkey so
i'm very happy great job by the
cincinnati police department
hey that's the spirit there the owner
says he bought a new security chain to
try to ward off any future thieves
and when we come back you'll hear from a
criminal defendant who authorities say
posted a video of a murder
on the internet now he's trying to take
back his guilty plea
can he do it we'll discuss right after
this
[Music]
a young man who admitted to murdering
his 17 year old girlfriend and making a
video of the killing
has taken the witness stand to try to
convince a judge to throw out his guilty
plea
brandon clark admitted in open court
earlier this year that he killed bianca
devins
and posted the video online but now he
claims his original attorney coerced him
into thinking his guilty plea was
somehow not final here's some of the
prosecutors questioning of clark in an
attempt to
make the police stick at times
prosecutors forcing clark to eat his own
words
and clark saying his attorney misled him
it has never been my intention to deny
my guilt in the events of july 14th
and this day should have come a lot
sooner
my attorney was adamant that i really
consider
where i would what i would be doing
today and what it meant
and i have and i have thought about it i
asked him if i could take the back the
plea at any time for any reason
and he told me yes if i accept her plea
of guilty today
this case will be over except for the
actual sentence
your answer yes your honor
two of defendant brandon clark's defense
attorneys testified at that hearing one
said
no self-respecting attorney would have
their client plead guilty to the max
which is what happened here
that first attorney denied giving some
of the advice the defendant
just claimed that he received a second
attorney
said the defendant wanted to fire the
first attorney who was prepping the case
for trial
indicated to me that he was planning or
wanted to fire mr d
bush because he did not want to try he
did not want to pursue a trial and that
mr nebush
was pursuing the extreme emotional
distress
over his objection
okay so that second attorney also
testified that the defendant
thought a trial would somehow impede his
story from becoming
public so eckland that's kind of
interesting usually defendants like
trials because then the story becomes
public right
um so here's the thing i think you know
this
is what happens when you're a criminal
defense attorney what happens is that
whatever you're telling your client they
hear something
else so um you know a defense attorney
can tell a client especially in georgia
like
hey you can't withdraw a plea within the
term of court
but sometimes they hear within whenever
you want
and after being in prison once you're in
prison for a while and once it all
becomes real
that's when you know the the wheels
start churning
and then sometimes people want to
withdraw their plea after the fact
and i think that's what's happening here
that sounds a lot like what's going on i
think your insight is right on the money
equine terry do you agree should the
judge
agree as well um with with eklund or
should the judge agree with the
defendant here and let him walk his plea
back
well aaron you know this is what i think
the judge has to consider both the
testimony of the defendant
and the attorney and so you know the
question really is
whether or not the plea was made
intelligently knowingly and voluntarily
and in order for the judge to make that
determination he's got to listen to both
sides and he has to understand what the
communication was
between the attorney and the client and
actually i think he needs to err on the
side of caution
and go with the client wow so that could
mean a new trial and i'm talking to some
local reporters who tell me the same
thing that ultimately that might be what
happens here this case may
wind up going to trial the fears locally
that it's just going to be very painful
for the family to watch that video get
played
of the actual killing eclin and terry
great to be here with you both here on
law and crime daily we'll do this again
sometime
the rest of us the normal crew will be
back next time for our discussions about
justice in america
[Music]
hi i'm dan abrams in the exploding legal
and true crime genre
law and crime is the only network that
has it all good evening and welcome
this is a complicated case don't really
jump to conclusions
we break down the case of a serial
killer another day of drama between both
sides
from multiple live trials daily to
original and compelling programming
the long crime network is everywhere and
we invite
you inside the jury box this
is law and crime
[Music]
you